i looked over at my dad i walked in he
was looking for jobs and he just retired
and at the time you just had a business
that tanked as well i didn't have any
income coming in said i'm looking at
this moped and looking at getting a job
with delivery it's a thousand pounds i'm
500 sure he came to the event and
everything changed from there literally
everything there's no such thing as the
mounting tops without the valleys last
month you bought your dream house which
was how much
thank you for coming down to my house
and given this opportunity for my
viewers to understand how you started
from basically nothing and have built up
a property million pound portfolio so
how did you guys meet how did you guys
meet and then i want to i want to be
asking you the hard questions about how
you've done this in such a i say quick
time because what you've achieved is you
know huge yeah we met in when ricky was
dj'ing so ricky was a dj doesn't do it
anymore but we wet in a local nightclub
so my best friend was a mutual friend of
ricky's she introduced us what did you
like about him so much was his dj skills
do you know what it actually was that
that really attracted me to him i'm big
kanye west band he played khan us and i
was like wow
this is it but also he was so his person
is so bubbly so smiley so likable yeah
and that's still today the thing that i
love about him the most so you met he
was a dj what were you doing at the time
so i was i just literally started out in
my network marketing career so i just
left my full-time job about six months
before meeting ricky so
i was in quite a scary time you know
navigating my life yeah what happened to
your job as a dj well what happened they
um they fired me but quit the same time
okay okay and uh yeah and you know when
all that happened i just thought it's
time for me to to kind of move on and
and do something different with my life
you know and you went really hardcore on
business um but you didn't have
mentors or education around you
i know you had a tough time the first
couple years tell me what happened when
i started with property we just met i
was dj and i stopped that when i started
i remember the thing i really changed
was i remember going home and my daddy's
worked all his life he's in his 60s i
worked all his life hard worker and i
went home one day and it just felt a bit
uncomfortable and i looked over at my
dad i walked in he was looking for jobs
and he just retired yeah yeah and i just
i was just thinking i just want to do
something yeah that's not the only like
my mom had just had open heart surgery
which was a a last-minute kind of shock
and i remember going to the hospital
walking in the doors and seeing my mum
with the tubes on her face and she's
just i'm thinking
i don't want my mum to come out of this
and worry about money my sister as well
i'm the youngest of three and my sister
has always had this dream of living on
the beach and she actually invested in
me to do the advanced training yeah
because you went to the one pound course
though yeah and then you registered for
some further training yeah i didn't i
wasn't able to pay for it myself yeah
because i had nothing to invest i
remember meeting your dad your mom yeah
your sisters and you were like this big
family yeah you were the youngest yeah
and they did back you to be fair
to my absolute shock why did were you
shocked you know i just ricky's so
hungry as a person but the fact that
they believe so much in him to invest
him in that way i think because it's not
something my family would do i found it
so endearing i was like wow the fact
that they believe so much and they were
right i mean thank god they did but it
was incredible when he came remember
when he came home and told me that he
had you know invested in the academy and
he was starting all this mentoring and
he was so excited i was it was it was
the adrenaline that came from him i was
like wow where have you been can i come
i need to get bit of this energy and at
the time you just had a business that
tanked as well right yeah tell me about
that because when we met that was kind
of where you were at what happened with
that well we we we moved abroad to to
work on this business but it wasn't just
case of movement it was like we we
loaded up the car with all everything we
had we sacrificed everything yeah we let
go of the apartment that i rented we
moved and we thought we were going to be
there for three months just to support
get the business off the ground we were
actually there for 18 months and when we
we got we came home
um
i had no no money in my bank account i
just paid a tax bill and that was all
the money that i had left i had nothing
and i remember coming it was september
2018
we got we came back to the uk
and i remember we just moved into this
you know really modest place renting it
and i just remember standing in the
kitchen thinking this is great but i
don't actually know how we're going to
pay the rent next month it was a hard
pill to swallow because 18 months of our
lives would happen it had just happened
in another country and it felt so
frustrating you must have experienced
similar feelings as a business owner
it's like when am i getting my break you
know i put in everything but i think for
me the hardest part of everything was
that when i started my business it took
off and then it tanked and then i had to
get it back up again and that's a really
hard thing to do as a business owner
because you start to think was it just
was i just lucky did i just get in at
the right time am i going to be able to
repeat that again you were just
messaging me on facebook like trying to
get free tips and bits yeah
i still look at them sometimes i was
applying for jobs and stuff i wasn't
getting any jobs i remember
at this point just to be clear you
hadn't done any of my training at that
point no no no quit your job in well
quit slash got fired perry had her thing
going on we're really trying and i think
everybody that you see that's super
successful has been there's no such
thing as the mountaintops without the
valleys you can't have the all mountain
tops leadership's built in the dip yeah
you know and you've got to be prepared
to risk everything which is what you did
so when when you reached out to me yeah
on facebook and what do you remember
what you said to me yeah it was a really
nice message i said hey samuel i hope
you're doing well thanks for sharing all
of your videos and advice i'm looking at
getting started on property and i'm
looking for events local to me um
any beginning tips to be useful thanks
and you replied literally
15 minutes later and i remember seeing
it and i was thinking he's replied oh my
goodness i opened it and i just sent you
this really nice way and all you wants
stop looking for events near you and do
whatever it takes and i remember
thinking man this guy
you know this guy this guy's a bit of a
dick
you know i was really nice i said hope
you're well because i respond to
everybody so i can't respond a nice long
message yeah i was just like just come
to the program bro i thought he'd been
quite direct so i thought i'd be direct
too and i sent you a picture
and it was it was a booking confirmation
of a free program and i just see you
there yeah you know and the crazy thing
is i go to this program brought my whole
family along you know
sisters and um we enrolled onto the
advanced training my sister invested in
me to do it and the crazy thing is you
know i go into the advanced training and
within a week of the advanced training i
got my first rent to rent deal
and that made 800 pounds a month i've
got a second one made 1600 pounds
financially free what did you think at
this point when you saw him suddenly
getting all these rental rents and stuff
were you worried or no i wasn't worried
because he was putting in
the work like he was making phone calls
every single day and the way he was
speaking bearing in mind uh you know we
were working on this business together
and then he'd started his own thing that
made me a bit nervous
and
the way his work ethic what i was
watching the phone calls the rejection
everything and it i don't know you all
you it took however many phones 161
calls that was it yeah he would go to
costa and do it from there like so he
could sit down because we didn't have an
office or anything like that so he could
actually feel like he was in a
professional i think i changed my
environment yeah i remember going across
i used to buy a cluster every morning
and i'd make it last all day so i didn't
have to buy another i used to drop them
off on the way to the gym wow and um
and hearing that resilience as soon as
he got his first one set it up it after
that it was like clockwork once you got
that first one the first one was always
the hardest yeah he was going from there
he was so confident a month prior you
were literally applying for delivery
jobs yeah i applied for a job with
deliverer and it got rejected because
they didn't i didn't have any transport
didn't have a car i didn't have a moped
so we were like thinking what should we
do and we thought yeah let's get a moped
so we started looking and the cheapest
moped was a thousand pounds we were
going to finance if we couldn't get the
finances i had 500 pounds so i was 500
pounds sure and i remember messing you
know friends and stuff asking for the
money and everyone's just saying you
know we can't lend it to you we haven't
got it but there was there's one guy
that i grew up with he's like my best
friend um and i remember asking i
thought if i asked him for the money
but it's embarrassing asking for the
money so i kind of indirectly asked him
and i said i'm looking at this moped i'm
looking at getting a job with delivery
it's a thousand pounds i'm 500 sure um
i've got i've got 500 so i'm 500 sure
hope he'd be like i'll end it yeah but
he didn't he said hopefully you'll get
it soon
and i remember thinking you know even
even he doesn't believe in me that's a
low place though to be able to not even
afford a moped to get a job at deliveroo
and that's when we said we need to go
home
but we need to go back home and that in
that moment felt like the hardest
decision because we would then need to
come up with a deposit for a house to
rent i had a tax bill coming up which
can't be deferring it needed to be paid
and all of these other feelings that we
sold every piece of furniture that we
had in the house that we lived in when
we were abroad everything you could
think of for five pound four pound three
pound it was going all of that money do
you remember all of that cash we created
that got us home that got the tax bill
paid and got us our first month's
deposit and then
he came to the event and everything
changed from there literally everything
so you got your first rental event on
the program yeah which was about four or
five years ago yeah and now you're
property millionaires you're making tens
of thousands of pounds what do you think
the big switch was because i know you've
you've
exploded yeah i think i think for me um
it's environment
you know i just because
when i was surrounded with yourself and
you know other people are training it
it's just that environment that was like
pushes you on and other people wanting
to see you when yeah you know other
people wanting to pull you up and say
hey you've got this you can do this how
long did it take before you were able to
help your i know you said your dad and
you also your mom and like did were you
able to ever get them out of that slump
as well yeah so um within it was just
about about a year after we'd started
doing the rental rental we scaled up a
deal sourcing business you know and
after about a year of being on the
training not only did i help myself and
i managed to um say to my dad i didn't
have to work anymore you know nice we
retired my dad same with my mum i said
the same to my mum he didn't have to
work anymore so perry's mom as well yeah
said to prairie's mom you know she was
working he said you didn't have to work
anymore and recently we said to my
sister you know you don't have to to
work anymore i remember ricky saying to
me about three years ago was like i'm
running out of family members to retire
and that was when i was like you guys i
mean i've seen you as well speaking at
conferences and getting asked to speak
because of your success with your
fashion and everything and your business
success and i was like man i really need
ricky to come and share his story at one
of our events because his you know you
literally were dominating and rent to
rent dominating and deal sourcing i
could see the money that was coming in
and when you came and spoke at one of
our programs um everybody was just so
inspired and it kind of just became a
bit of a pattern to net you'd come down
as a volunteer yeah yeah and just sort
of share how did that make you feel when
i got invited to that first program
where you asked me to share i remember
meeting someone that you know was in a
similar situation and you know fast
forwarder for a few weeks their
situation had changed yeah and i just
that gave me fulfillment that for me was
like this is what i need to be doing now
showing other people this is possible
helping other people do the same what
does an average day look like then for
you guys now like how do you work
together on the businesses well an
average day is that we're very busy
we're very you know we're both i've just
turned 30
you know ricky's coming up to 30 and we
we're both
really in the peak of our careers
separately and together as well you know
ricky obviously loves being with you
guys and giving back and mentoring
people and helping people and i have
multiple businesses going on and getting
busier and busier so i primarily do work
from home i think it's important to say
that but i have a very regimented
schedule so like i book certain things
in i tend to film content in the morning
early afternoon do call zooms
afternoon what's your product then
because i know it's like mostly fashion
yeah so what what what is it like that
you're sort of selling selling wise i
work with skin care and beauty products
and i also work with fashion so i've my
own fashion collection with a really
successful
fashion brand so i have my own
collection with them so i really get to
get stuck into like designing and that
process and then i also the other side
of it is that i create content so i show
people how to style codes i create reels
you know kind of shortened versions and
you you mega successfully like your
instagram followers yeah how many how
many followers have you got now i'm on
i'm on nearly a half a million so four
hundred and fifty years and ricky you're
walking about in the street you know
sometimes people will come up and
they'll stop us because they'll have
seen us on the property yeah yeah yeah
yeah but recently with jet ski
someone came up and said oh excuse me
excuse me
and i thought oh they're probably maybe
they've come to see me maybe and they
said are you perry's partner
can i get a picture because we're
massive fans of perry it's so funny but
you know what like all off aside people
do not realize it is hard work i do not
stop like it's a constant 24 7 and you
understand with your youtube always
thinking of your initiative has to
constantly keep ticking you go to bed at
night and you're thinking of new content
ideas new ways to get seen yeah you know
but it's all about giving value seeing
youtube as well being competitive about
about the finances like ricky will sell
a few deals and you'll be like oh oh
yeah
yeah yeah well i overhear him on the
phone
and we are quite competitive if i hear
him we'll get really excited don't we
this is the thing i think as well when
you're successful i think it's important
always celebrate those wins whether
they're big or small and that's what we
always do so i'll hear him study a few
deals and i'm like right okay now i need
to get on my game and make enough
commissions today to match him and
that's just like healthy it's funny
though because normally with couples
there's one who's kind of like the
leader the driver and then the other one
sort of plays a more supportive role
whether that's the man or the woman but
with you two you're kind of like both
the leaders but we are both but
sometimes it changes like sometimes
it can be me being the supportive one
especially with ricky recently because
he's just been smashing it like
everything he's been doing and i've
bought so many houses recently yeah but
i like to play that supportive role but
then recently it's been with me loads of
things have come into kind of fruition
at once which is always the way doesn't
it how do you maintain a healthy
relationship with so much about business
going on do you ever just go for a date
night and not talk about work
i think i think we're quite excited
aren't we at the moment so we enjoy
talking about what we've got going on
yeah but communication is just
everything and when we do spend time
together it's quality time yeah but we
communicate like you know when ricky's
with you guys you know doing what he
loves he's not on his phone like we
can't be texting all the time and
talking and that's actually the best
thing ever because when he comes home
tells me about all the success that the
students are having he tells me about
you know oh this person just started and
they're already financially free and i
love hearing it last month you bought
your dream house which was how much
1.1 million that's a good price yeah
very good price good negotiator yeah it
was good negotiation yeah very very good
i know you're referring that to like a
really high standard as well um and
you've you've just repaid your sister
yeah we've invested in you that's a bit
of seed money yeah have you returned the
favor so we bought um a house on the
beach have you completed yeah oh that's
amazing yeah how much was that that was
560 thousand it must feel weird that
five years ago you couldn't afford to
pay rent and you were getting declined
from delivery and now you're just buying
half a million pounds and declined for
moped finance okay let's just put that
into perspective [ __ ] them
yeah you can call me now
that's crazy though isn't it well you're
talking about that on the way up here
weren't we yeah and you're a very humble
couple you don't talk about how much
you're earning and drag but you're
earning tens of thousands of pounds a
month yeah and it's just going up and up
and up your properties are going up in
value what's life like now i know you
still work really hard but how's life
changed we do work hard
but we we live we live life on our terms
yeah for me it's it's about freedom and
being able just to make the choices that
you want to make just to give you an
example we were in dubai um in march and
i was it was business ambassador wasn't
it because i was launching a collection
like a fashion collection
and we was i was talking to my sisters
on whatsapp and my one of my sisters
said to me i'm really upset i've got to
cancel my holiday in september to crete
they were supposed to go 10 days all
inclusive because my car's broken i need
to get a new car and i don't want to
finance it so the money that we have the
holiday is gone and i remember me and
ricky just looked at each other and i
was like i'm gutted i don't want to read
this like it and it annoys me that she's
in that position because she studied for
five years at university she's a
veterinary nurse but the money just
doesn't stretch her partner is an
accountant but it's the same thing he's
still studying now so we just decided
there and then do you know what we've
booked a holiday we're going to take you
all on holiday we're going in october
got taken to the airport when they're
going to find out at the airport where
they're going but it's that that for me
that exact thing is what money does for
me yes it's great you can buy what you
want we haven't got kids yet i'm sure
but you know with your kids you
experience the same sort of thing but
it's just being able to for us family is
everything we love to give back to work
and that's why i love you guys so much
and that's why we've become so close
because we've got loads of people that
have become millionaires
through the training but the fact that
you're such into you've helped your own
family but and your own friends but now
i mean you're helping finance some of
the stuff that we're doing we've got a
lot of stuff with the charity we do we
do deals together as well so
five years ago i used to be in the room
with samuel at the trainings and he'd
come over and he'd help me and i'll be
started thinking
you know like there he is it's samuel
leeds and now i spend you know so much
time with you and your family and here
it's like
it's crazy
you know it's crazy how far we've come
what do you think when you see people
that were like you
and now you have the opportunity to be
able to through our training company
which we've now partnered together
be able to have the opportunity to help
mentor them and pull them up like what
what is it about that that you love so
much it's just the fulfillment of seeing
other people you know that i can relate
to that were in that similar situation
when i see them and it's like you know
showing them that this is possible
helping them through that process and
then afterwards you know them
just seeing what they can do with it
that's what gives me fulfillment now and
you're a massive advocate you're not on
any commission no
for the training even though you
sell it so passionately you'll be like
you're not on any commission obviously
we do pay you to speak as a speaker
because because
i
are you sure you want to keep doing this
for free yeah
i'll keep doing it because that's the
thing there's a lot of people that would
love to say to milton can i speak on
stage or can i and they're either trying
to grow their own brand or they just
want to get paid but the fact that you
did it you just completely didn't ask
for anything and after a year you were
the one that said to me no we're gonna
we're gonna start yeah after a year i
thought i bet ricky's gonna be like come
on now i've been but you didn't no and
then another year went by and you were
just like nah man i just love doing it
yeah i'm making loads of money in
property
and and perry's making loads of money in
fashion and we do i just want to help
and then that was when i thought you
know what i value that and i got to a
point where i thought we we couldn't
really afford to lose you because people
were coming to the programs sometimes
specifically to see you yeah it's
freaking gonna be here loads of people
will come in you'd meet people out in
dubai and do anything so they've come in
flying so i thought you know there needs
to be a fair exchange yeah what made you
not set up your own training company why
did you not set up your own property
training company what made you want to
kind of sort of team up with what we're
doing firstly i've been through your
process i've been through your training
and hundreds of others have as well and
it's a proven process that works as long
as you take the action it's proven to
work and the mission that you're on you
know i just got hooked onto that mission
with you so the reason i wouldn't do it
myself and i haven't done it is because
firstly you know i've been through yours
and the best is already there yes like
yeah you know why why would i i don't
need to do it i don't know i don't need
to i'd rather just be part of a mission
that's bigger than me you know partner
with yourself and you know
do it together yeah yeah what are your
personal goals then
my personal goals are
to just keep on helping as many people
as i possibly can
change their life and in effect help
others you know what that sounds cheesy
but i know that it's true yeah because i
know yeah people might think oh whatever
but i see ricky literally you'll know
this of course like someone will get a
rent to rent deal or something and then
they'll oh my gosh i've got viewing on
tuesday and they'll be like i'll come
with you i'll be like listen it's all
good i'm coming with you i'll be on the
other side of the world you know i'm
coming he does he drives all over the
place and he's not getting paid to do it
just because he knows that they've come
on the program and they've got something
and he's just off yeah also when he
started like and when you started doing
viewings that
what you had that mentoring really
helped you
when you you know
it's uncomfortable and when i know that
you know when i'd invested although my
sister it was kind of bigger for me
because my sister invested in the
training so i was like i really need to
make this work but i know when someone
invests you know we take that very
seriously you know there's a sense of
responsibility so i know if someone's
invested firstly they're serious and
when they get a view in and i can see
them like ah sometimes i'm just like you
know what
i'm going to come and help you i'm going
to come and help you get this right i
see it all the time
perry when will enough ever be enough
will they ever get to a point where
you're like all right i don't know this
is a question that i asked myself
pretty isn't it like daley ricky always
says to me
he says you get to the top of the
mountain
and then you say i want to get to what
did you say to me one time you say you
get to the top of the mountain and
you're at the top and you're like no i
need to go up again but there's no
mountain for you to go to but i'm always
in my head you know recreating or
redefining what i actually want i think
for me the moment where i'll probably
say enough is enough when i have when we
have kids which
i don't know when that's going to be but
i've said to myself i'm 30 i want the
next five years now because i think 30s
is the new 20s like 30s is the new 20s
but you got your [ __ ] together right
like you've got you got it together so
for me
next five years i'm drilling in hard in
every aspect of what both of us can we
want to buy more properties you know we
want to get at least another two
properties by the end of the year and
then i think after five years i'll see
where i'm at but i will never be the
person ever and you will never be either
that can just
be a parent being a parent is the
greatest job you can ever have but i
will not be a parent where i just i
can't not be involved in my business
days or be involved in exciting projects
it's not when your life ends for me
yeah i just think that and that is
another reason why we want to help our
family so much because when we are
blessed enough you know fingers crossed
to have children our family right there
for us they're not having to miss like
you know ricky
is the only son in his family he's going
to be carrying on his legacy for his
family which means so much to your dad
and your mom his mum and dad are not
going to miss a moment of their
grandchild's life what does financial
freedom mean to you well financial
freedom is just when your
reoccurring income
covers or is equal to a greater than
your living expenses which by the way
everyone's even expensive going up right
now yeah you know yeah but what i've
seen you know is
i've done it myself and i've seen
hundreds of others do it become
financially free
very quickly yeah you know because if
you just cover your living expenses you
can do that
quickly yeah you know that's what
my my definition would be yeah
if you're talking about actual
definition that's what it is but i think
for me personally
is literally about being able to wake up
in the morning
and make a choice like the choice might
be what car you drive where you live
what coves you wear and it's not even
about materialistic choices it's just
about having that freedom to choose
because so many people unfortunately
don't have that you know so for me
that's what it's about just having the
freedom to choose and not having to
check my bank account every five seconds
and i used to have a notes on my phone i
would write down every single
transaction that i did because i had to
literally count the pennies that i had
so i could pay back debt collectors just
to have enough money to put five pounds
in my car to get to work do you think
you appreciate being rich more when
you've been poor oh
yeah 100 i think so as well not even a
million trillion billion so when people
are struggling financially really they
should be like great you know what i
remember these days with a smile when
your back's against the wall and this is
what we said about
our business took off and then it tanked
when we moved abroad
when your back is against the wall it
feels like at the time everything's
against you but that is when you learn
the most and then when you do turn that
corner i look back on who i was then and
who i am now and i thank my former self
you know thank you for the challenges
thank you for the obstacles because
they've given us what we have today what
do you think about the cost of living
crisis that's happening at the moment in
inflation because i personally worry for
people that are just in regular jobs at
the moment totally we were sitting with
your family weren't we talking about if
i earned say 1500 pound a month if you
combined as a couple and that so each if
you have like a if you live down south
we live down south the house prices are
really really high just for a modest
three-bed house
like my sister just bought one it was
like 400 grand so it's like a thousand
pound mortgage by the time you add all
the bills and everything there's nothing
left by the time you even if you rent it
by the time you paid your rent or your
mortgage and you know you've got that
you've got your living stuff yeah
you haven't even had a meal yet what
advice would you give them to somebody
that's watching this that wants to get
started in business of some kind
for me my advice is you have just got to
do it now so if you've got something in
your mind don't let your brain stop you
just do it yeah i think as well like not
just don't over think yeah don't open it
as motivation yeah use this as a
motivation and a push to say you know
what i need to make a change and look at
what's going to be the best case likely
case in worst case don't let it stop you
if you've got an idea or if you want to
enroll in something you want to do
something new don't not do it because of
the crosstalk of it and make it work how
do you think the cost of living crisis
and the recession that we're potentially
entering into now will affect your
businesses like with the property stuff
you've just bought a lot of houses yeah
like what do you think's going to happen
to properties well for me with property
does it doesn't matter what happens
they'll always
from the business point of view there's
always people that are looking to go and
stay somewhere service accommodation
there's always people that are looking
to go on holiday go on business trips
and they need accommodation and you know
we're gonna provide yeah i was just
gonna say i think that people are gonna
curb their spending think about it
what the first thing people are going to
do is they're going to stop going on
like fancy holidays abroad and stuff
like that because you know it's an
unnecessary expense so what do they do
in replacement of that they're going to
staycation in the uk
yeah but they do yeah that's what we saw
after the pandemic as well you know
that's what people will do with hmos
it's like when when we have a recession
and people are struggling that everyone
wants to rent rooms especially now as
well with the booze going up so it's
actually going to massively help us yeah
as bad as that sounds yeah if you own
stuff
and cost of living happens well that's a
good thing because you own stuff yeah so
if things go up and you own stuff then
you're getting richer yeah the people
who are struggling the people that don't
own anything they'll get poorer because
they don't own anything yeah my advice
would be
get started owning stuff now businesses
assets
learn if ricky hadn't gone on the
academy i don't know what we would have
done we wouldn't have we would have been
fine that we would have wrecked it
pretty fast
and also that academy has probably paid
for itself now oh hundreds oh yeah yeah
hundreds of times over one of the things
me and ricky talk about a lot and really
believe is the importance of having a
good circle around you yeah a circle and
we are very inclusive of who we have in
our circle we're not picky you know we
want to give people a chance and i think
having the right people around you is so
vital to success what do you think about
that perry 100
the number one thing i would say about
your circle and who you surround
yourself with it's very simple if you
don't aspire to be like that person
don't take advice from them because it
blows my mind how many people take
advice from somebody that's a nobody and
i think why are you taking advice about
money from someone that's broke or
someone that's in debt that was me five
years ago i would take money advice from
people that had none and then i took
that advice and it got me nowhere so for
me i keep my circle small i keep it
intimate but with the right people that
i truly would love to be like myself
that's so good
and i i think that you know one of the
reasons i love you guys so much is
because 2018 2019 you know we had a
rough ride we had a lot of
trolls as my brand kind of blew up we
had media stories yeah which mostly have
now been removed we had a lot of a lot
of [ __ ] you know yeah um and you guys
stood with me through that and still
this is a company what did you think
ricky what did you think when because
you were personally getting because you
were a student at the time now i know
you're a trainer and a mentor but at the
time you were on the academy and you
were going through it how did that
affect did that affect you did you ever
feel like jumping ship when i was
getting all of these comments and stuff
like that for me i kind of had like a
shield around me because it was like
i know this works because i've done it
yeah so when it happened i'd already got
rent rents i'd already started deal
sourcing so i knew it worked and so
everything that was being said was like
just rebounding off because i was fully
focused and i knew that the process
worked and there was nothing that could
be said that would ever you know there
were obviously there was
there were some points where i thought
is this going to work out you know is
everything everyone was telling you
weren't there that they rent to rants
and all this stuff oh it won't it won't
stay around it's gonna all crumble but i
was like
i was i was like maybe that close but
the thing that stopped me from actually
saying you know what i'm done with this
was
knowing that the process worked and that
i had done it yeah and how
loyal you'd been to me as a student as
well have you had to deal with any
haters with you yeah yeah there's a very
nasty um blogging site that um
that should be banned by the government
but it's not and it's basically supposed
to be a safe place where people can
write their opinions will opinions then
turn into bullying and turn into you
know vile comments and there's basically
if you're an influencer or if you're a
person you're probably on there if
you're a person of you know attention
let's say someone will start a thread so
they might be like samuel leads blah
blah blah and then someone jumps onto it
and then it becomes like a thread and i
remember i we just announced that my
first edit was coming out with the brand
that i work with i was on the highest
high possible it was my it was wasn't it
remember we went to london to shoot it
it was my biggest career break today
it's something that i've manifested and
worked on for so long and it launched it
sold out within minutes it was so
successful and the day after someone
just happened to forward me the link to
the thread and they said just take a
look at this and the things that were
being written about me the pure lies the
insults to my mum you know about my
finances or just about my works about my
attitude my personal everything that
just totally ridiculed and i remember i
sat i stood in the shower i cried my
eyes out and then i got it out and i was
like never ever again will they get
anything from me like that's it now how
do you deal with that because i think
every
famous person or someone that's very
successful and is in the public
spotlight i'm not saying that you're
fast yeah but everybody that is in the
spotlight and is very successful i'm
sure has been through that i know a lot
of friends that are very very well known
celebrities they've all been through it
how do you deal with that
when you're getting that kind of abuse
for me it was just being straight
staying true to me yeah staying true to
me and you know stepping outside of it
and looking at right what are they
saying is it factual and is it true yeah
and if it's not forget it yeah you know
and i look at it and i look now and i
think right
what i was doing was working i was i'm a
part of a great company that is helping
other people the process works so when i
actually think about it logically i just
thought no i'm staying true to myself
here you know i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna change or or quit or do anything
like that because
i'm i need to stay true to myself i
think if it's coming from a good place
if a mentor or somebody close to you
who's actually coming from a good place
can give you criticism oh totally yeah
it's uninvited opinions that i don't
appreciate and i still get it from time
to time and i just bat it away it's like
whatever but i'm obviously now in this
industry which i was catapulted into it
very fast and i had to learn very fast i
know people's careers have been ruined
because of this and people have mentally
suffered and you know people have to get
help and therapy so that's one of the
reasons that we decided to sue them
because
because we thought we need to make a
stand not just not just for myself and
my customers and my staff and my but
also just to show people that it's not
acceptable the the main reason that i
stuck with the company at that time
because i sat back and i thought
actually if if this keeps going and
something goes wrong with the company
because of this
look at all the people that are being
helped look at the people that are
coming through and having success
it's just wrong if that has happened and
that's what made me stick with it
because i knew it worked and i thought
if i step back now from the company then
i'm i'm doing something wrong
yeah what's your most exciting project
at the moment
well the latest one the brighton house
yeah the beach house in brighton
sister's gonna be living there for six
months of the year and then they're
gonna rent it out so in the winter
months that went it out yeah there's
someone in there now until christmas
christmas so it's like a holiday home
for her yeah yeah so cool yeah and
you've managed to make it profitable
still yeah straight away straight
straight away
we had someone ready to go in before we
completed what did your dad think about
because you retired your dad quite quite
quickly what does he think about what
you guys have done within property and
business oh i was with him yesterday and
we were we were in the car and he just
turned to me and he said you know i'm so
proud of you yeah he is so proud yeah
he's very he's very proud i've had some
good conversations with your parents
since you've become very successful
they're beautiful so what were your
final pieces of wisdom and advice for
someone
realizing that actually maybe a job
doesn't cut the mustard anymore i want
to get into business i want to be i
don't want to have to worry about money
anymore in finance i want to start a
business what would you say i think for
me it's not i'm really passionate about
what i do but i do a lot of different
things so i think what holds people back
these days is they're a little bit like
well i don't know what i want to do i
don't know what my space is but it
doesn't have to be like you have to be
into fashion or you have to be people
say to them all the time i want to be an
influencer but i don't love fashion well
there's loads of other things you can
influence about you are essentially an
influencer in property you know people
wouldn't think that that's the thing but
it really is but i think if you want to
make change you have to get up and do it
now like i think that people always next
week next month next year well that
turns into the next 10 years and you've
never done anything so set yourself a
challenge to do something straight away
whether it's hop on a webinar you know
where that's giving some value about
something whether it's message an
influencer and ask them some advice like
ricky message you do something that's
going to make you feel a little bit
uncomfortable make you feel a little bit
on edge and that will be the start of
your journey to doing something bigger
and better um i was just making a
decision making a decision just to say
you know what this is what i'm going to
do and nothing's going to stop yeah and
going all in on that and two and too
many people so one other thing are
scared of what other people think that
is the biggest thing that i think holds
people back and i let go of that i know
that i'm a bit different i know that i'm
loud i know that i have a lot of energy
and i'm you know i'm always peeing ideas
24 7. that's who i am and i know that
people have said behind my back that
they find me too much and they find me
intense but that's i'm being authentic
i'm successful because i've stayed true
to myself and the people that love me
and follow me and follow my content and
message me on instagram every day my
royal followers they love me for who i
am and they know that i'm authentic what
i'd say as well is you know
don't tell people what you're going to
do show them yeah and then pull them up
when you've done it yeah 100
because ricky you've influenced loads of
your friends together
we meet people on holiday and they're at
the course the week after well we're
going to be running um we're running a
course next month aren't we which is a
pound yeah you come down to what
what what happens to these uh these one
pound events rex oh what happens what
doesn't happen you know you you see
what's possible you you'll go through it
yourself you know me and you our team
will all be there we go through it we
show
what you can do and how it's possible
but then is the interesting thing this
is where it gets good because once we've
shown others how to do it we then get
them to do it there and then as well
with the support of us yeah it's just an
incredible day it's where i started
which is why i'm so passionate about
keep coming back and and showing other
people because this that's how i started
at one of them do you think a pound
perry is it a bit expensive do we need
to drop it probably 50 pairs you could
probably no joke find a pound on the
floor if you got tired enough yeah well
guys thanks for coming down and sharing
your story and also thank you for your
friendship and your support
thanks
[Music]
you